[MUSIC]
Welcome, everyone, to
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
alumni panel for the Western region.
I'm going to go ahead and
just get started talking about
what you guys can expect today.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
my name's Elisa Koppl.
I'm a member of the MBA
admissions team here at Stanford.
I'm joined today with five panelists, and
the focus today is on hearing
the perspectives of folks who
are residing in currently the Western
region of the United States.
So we'll get to hear firsthand experiences
of people who have been to the GSB.
This session specifically
is 45 minutes long.
Just to set some expectations,
we'll start off with introductions with
our panelists and
then open it up for Q and A.
So I will be looking at the Q and
A pod for questions and
trying to moderate discussion
amongst with our panelists.
This will be 45 minutes,
we'll do some introductions.
And like I said,
feel free to submit questions throughout.
I will end this session talking about
other types of events that we offer.
But today we're going to really
jump right into questions and
answers with our panelists.
If you're looking for
more information on our program,
on admissions criteria and
things like that, we do have info
sessions that we offer throughout
the summer, the next few months.
And we encourage you to check
on our events page for more,
but I will talk about more of
those events at the end of this.
So, again, thank you everyone for
joining today.
We are so excited to have you for
this panel.
Because this is a session that is
focused on the Western region and
we have panels this summer focused
on regions, focused on industries,
and I wanted to share,
because this is the Western region,
a bit of information about
our class of 2021 profile.
As you can see, about 66 countries
are represented in the GSP class.
So an incredibly global class of students.
We have about 420 students in each class.
But again,
today's focus is the Western region.
And as you'll see,
incoming in class of 2021,
about 64% of students were
from the United States.
I want to take some time to have each of
our panelists today introduce themselves.
We're joined, like I said,
by five great panelists.
I'm very excited to have all of them.
I'm here today to share
their perspectives.
I'm going to ask each of them to go around
and state their name, their class year.
And if each of you could share perhaps
your favorite academic experience,
so maybe a class project, faculty.
What was your favorite academic
experience when you were at the GSB?
And we'll have each of you answer that and
then we'll get started
with more questions.
So Norris, why don't we start with you?
>> Great, thanks for the introduction.
So, again, my name is Norris.
And I graduated class of 2019.
And one academic program I
really liked was the SSEP, or
Stafford Supply Exchange Program I
did in the fall of 2018.
And that was really cool
because I got to learn about
on ByteDance before it became
super huge in the United States.
>> Awesome, thanks.
Sunny, why don't we go next with you?
>> Hi, everyone.
My name is Sunny Kumar.
I'm a graduate of the MBA program as
well as the MD program from Stanford.
My favorite academic
experience was leading a GST,
a global study trip, to Greece,
where we looked at how the economic
crisis from 2009 affected
their healthcare system.
Even more relevant today, as we're all
facing another healthcare crisis and
learning how to adapt in this situation.
>> Great, thank you.
Marlo, I know you're on by phone and
we'd love to have you introduce yourself.
>> Excellent, hi everyone.
This is Marlo, apologies again
that I don't have video, but
quick background on me, class of 2016.
I currently work in private
equity now in Los Angeles.
And I would my favorite academic
experience was actually probably taking
the search fun class and learning
a little bit about almost a micro private
equity type world combined
with entrepreneurship.
I think it was a really interesting
way to learn about business.
>> Great, thank you.
Mariana, why don't you go next?
>> Yeah, hey everyone,
I'm Mariana, from 2013 class.
I work at Facebook now
as a product manager.
And my favorite academic experience, For
me, it was the electronic
business class with Mendelson.
I know it seems it sounds so basic,
but I come from the East Coast.
And I didn't really
know enough about tech.
And it really opened my eyes.
And I remember our final exam was about
Airbnb and I was like, this is crazy.
And now I'm like, my gosh,
it's the biggest business ever.
[LAUGH] So it was really great exposure.
>> That's awesome.
Thanks for sharing.
And Vidya,
we'll have you introduce yourself now.
>> Everyone, I'm Vidya.
I graduated from the GSB in 2012.
And now I am up in Seattle working for
the Strategic Investment Fund
at the Gates Foundation.
My favorite academic experience at the GSB
was the bio design innovation class,
which I hope they're still teaching,
I'm not sure.
Which is kind of an interdisciplinary
class between the business school,
medical school, and
a bunch of the engineering programs.
Where you basically have a specific
medical need that you choose and
you develop a medical device together.
Kind of go through the entire process of,
kind of the design process
to come up with something and
figure out the regulatory pathway.
And my team, the year that I did it,
they were focused on global health needs.
And I got to basically develop
a saliva-based diagnostic for
neonatal jaundice.
It was just such a cool experience and
working across people with several
backgrounds, so I loved that.
>> Great, thank you so much for sharing.
I see actually a question that's a great
follow up to you guys sharing your
favorite academic experience.
We got asked really about
the leadership courses and
leadership curriculum at the GSB.
I was wondering if maybe one or
two of you could share,
of the leadership courses that you maybe
took, whether it was leadership labs or
an elective that you took or
executive challenge,
this is a question from Andrew Hue,
what was most transformative for you?
And really, how did it help you
develop your leadership skills?
So kind of a follow up academic question.
Why don't we start with
Norris to answer that?
>> Sure, so one thing about leadership
labs that I've taken with me,
it's pretty basic, it's like
the action impact feedback format.
And in our startup,
we have monthly climate checks
where we actually utilize that.
And it seems to be a pretty good way
where you get specific information about
something you did and
how it impacts others.
Pretty simple, but [LAUGH] often people
forget that they don't actually know what
you did to make them feel that way.
So it's good to remember that.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
Sunny, could you share about leadership,
perhaps something that helped you
develop your leadership skills or
helped kind of on your
transformation through business law?
Absolutely, for
me the most impactful academic experience
I had related to leadership was
a course called interpersonal dynamics
that many of you may be familiar with.
The core nature of this
course is to help you,
in a small group, learn how to
communicate more effectively and
in a different style than I
think most people are aware of.
Coming from a medical background,
we often are in positions where we're
delivering hard news, challenging news.
But I actually think unequivocally the
best communication experience and learning
I got was from interpersonal dynamics
during my entire tenure at Stanford.
>> Awesome, thanks.
I see another question out there
just about career pivoting.
And that one we shared this screen for
a few of you,
there were some of you who
did pivot in your careers.
I'd love to hear from, we'll start with
Mariana about what you were doing before
the GSB, and maybe how the GSB helped you
prepare for what you wanted to do after.
And then I'd also love for
Marlo to follow up and answer that too.
But we'll start with Mariana.
>> Yeah, so
career pivoting is very common.
Before business school,
I was in consulting and private equity.
And I thought I was going to go
back to private equity afterwards.
That's what I was gearing myself towards.
I actually ended up switching into tech.
So now I work at Facebook.
And a lot of that just came from exposure.
I think that's one of the best
things about Stanford is that
the alumni come back, obviously.
[LAUGH] And in courses,
you hear from a lot of
folks who are running major
companies in different industries.
So it gave me a lot more perspective.
So being on the east coast,
for me, finance and
consulting were the biggest and
most important industries.
And then I come to the west coast and
I realized actually there's
a whole other world out there.
And so for me, was gaining exposure
to the industry of tech and
then narrowing once I figured
out that's where I wanted to go.
Things that helped were coursework just
to get the survey of all the things, and
then the internship is basically
like a free pass to do anything.
So I contacted this founder who I know,
asked to be his number two,
and basically just followed him
around the world for my summer.
And that's how I figured out it was
definitely the industry for me.
And so I think it's pretty common.
I'd say, keep an open mind, and don't be
surprised if you go in thinking one thing
and then end up doing something
entirely different afterwards.
>> Great, thank you.
Marlo, do you want to answer that too?
I know you pivoted when you
came to business school too.
>> Sure, so before business school,
I was in consulting on a kind of very
traditional path to return to consulting.
Then got to the GSB, and similarly,
I got exposed to a bunch of new people,
a bunch of new ideas, and realized I was
actually really interested in investing.
And so I was pretty fortunate that
I realized that fairly early and
ultimately worked with the Career Center
to pursue an internship in
private equity on the East Coast.
Had a great experience,
realized it was what I wanted to
do kind of full time after the GSB, and so
ultimately decided to go down that path.
And so I've been in Los Angeles
doing private equity for
the last four years, kind of building upon
some of what I learned in my internship.
And really glad that I got the chance
over that three-month period to
try out a different career.
Because I think otherwise,
as much as I really enjoyed consulting,
I think it's been exciting
to make a change.
>> Great, thanks, you guys.
There's actually a question
from Anna in the audience.
She's kind of piggybacking off of
this career pivoting question.
So I'll follow up with Mariana and
Marlo but
then probably have someone else chime in.
That really is about, how many of you came
to business school with the intent to
pivot, and how many of you were
exposed to something while here?
And so many of you are doing such
different things out there that I'd love
to hear, a follow up to Mariana and Marlo.
But then maybe also, Bidya,
you could chime in here too.
So Mariana, it sounded like you
were exposed to things as you came.
So maybe you didn't have
the intent of pivoting, but
if you could share more of what you were
thinking as you came into business school.
>> Yeah, I did not intend to pivot, so
I was in private equity, and I expected
to remain in private equity but just in a
different geography and a different scale.
And when I got to business
school I basically
figured out that I wanted to create.
And for me, I got value from like
actually creating things that without me,
in the world wouldn't exist, and
I wasn't getting that from investing.
And so it just became really clear
where I was getting my energy from.
And I think it's been a good
barometer of my life is,
what drains your energy,
what gives you energy?
And so you can try on a few things and the
way to try things on in business school is
through coursework, through your peers.
So almost everyone has done a career
that could be interesting for you.
And so just by talking to folks in
your class, you can get a sense for
what it's really like and
ask honest questions.
Because no one has a vested
interest in lying or
persuading you one way or another.
You're there with them for
two years, most people aren't trying
to push you one way or another.
So it's a really good safe
space to get that background.
And then going into sort
of what I did after school,
I started my own company, which gave me
a lot of different functions within tech.
And then when I switched into Facebook,
I narrowed even further into product.
So not a straight line, but
Stanford helped me figure out
what's the general playing field.
Okay, where within that I want to play?
Okay, why?
And then the launchpad to pursue it.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Marlo, maybe you could chime in,
and then we'll go to Bidya.
>> Perfect, yeah, I would say mine
was somewhat exposure based as well.
I mean, I had a combination of kind of
meeting classmates and putting faces
to the career with respect to something
I'd heard of, but didn't know quite as
much about until I met individuals who
were in that path or come from that path.
I also took a couple courses,
I took an investing class,
a couple investing classes,
I took some financial modeling classes.
I also joined some clubs,
I was in a couple investing clubs and
private equity club and whatnot.
And I think that helped also just sort of
surround me with new ideas that made me
realize that was something
I was interested in.
>> Excellent, and Bidya, I know you
also switched careers and pivoted.
When you came,
was that kind of a goal of yours to
pivot when you started at the GSB?
>> I think for
me there was definitely intent to pivot.
So my background before coming to the GSB
is I worked in kind of traditional finance
in New York at Goldman, first starting
on the investment banking side,
then working within the kind
of prop hedge fund.
And I knew when I was doing that,
that I was gaining skills, but
I wanted to apply those skills somewhere
very different in the course of my career.
But found that when you work
that many hours a day or
a week, you can't really spend a lot
of time thinking about the transition.
And for me, my passion area had always
been around international development.
And I think through actually
my time at Goldman,
I gained a lot of interest in healthcare.
So I became interested in global health.
But the problem that I faced was there's
a bazillion things you can go do in global
health.
And I have this particular set of
skills that relates to kind of
understanding companies and
how the private sector works.
And so how do I figure out what
that right role is for me?
So I came into business school
with the intent to explore that.
So not knowing what the answer would be,
but wanting to look at, maybe working for
the government or multilateral agencies.
Maybe working for
companies on the ground or for
US companies that were kind of trying
to send innovation over there.
And maybe staying in the investment field,
which is a function I really liked.
But having that investment be much more
kind of geared towards bringing innovation
to the developing world.
And I did my internship at
the Gates Foundation, which I feel so
grateful to have been at Stanford.
because that year,
when 2011, my summer was the first
year they offered an internship.
And the only places they offered it
were Stanford Business School and Udub.
Just because actually,
the CEO of the Gates Foundation at
the time had was a Stanford alum.
That was the only reason.
It was very fortuitous.
I actually did my internship totally out
of investing, focused on global health,
got a lot of exposure, and
found this team that I now work on.
Which was kind of the perfect combination
of the skills and the interests, and
found my way there.
But I also did a lot of searching,
like the others said, in classes and
projects, and demixes, which are the small
internships you can do over the summer.
I worked in India.
So it was just a great kind of test
ground, I think, to try different things.
>> Great, yeah, for sure.
I'd love for Sunny to chime in
here about intend to pivot,
but I'm going to broaden it a bit for
you specifically.
We have a few questions in
the audience about dual degrees,
and I'm coming to the GSB, and
kind of how is that possible?
So I'd love for
you to share when you decided doing
a dual degree was the right thing for you?
And just what your intent, or
original thinking was at that time, and
maybe how it laid out as
you went to business.
>> Sure, absolutely.
I'll give you guys a little bit of
context in that when I came to Stanford,
I knew that the entire university was well
known for having a lot of support for
dual degrees at the Medical School.
Almost every student does not graduate
in the traditional four years.
They take at least one
year to do something else.
And when it came time for
me to make that decision,
I did not actually know that it
was going to be business school.
I wanted to explore.
And the primary thing I was motivated
by was I wanted to expand my horizons.
I knew medicine very well.
I knew clinical research very well.
Many of my colleagues continued
to double down on that.
I knew I wanted to do something else.
So when I was in clinical rotations, I
found that there's just such a big divide
between how physicians think
medicine should be practiced.
And how healthcare administrators
actually implement medical practice,
and I wanted to get to
the bottom of that gap.
And I thought the best way to do so would
be to get a business school education.
Build out that experience,
return to clinical practice, and
then be able to kind of navigate
both sides of that course.
I think as Mariana said,
it was not a straight line path for me.
There were many twists and
curves along the way.
But perhaps the most impactful thing
about doing a dual degree at Stanford
was that it just gave me
such a broad exposure to so
many things outside of my specific
specialty, which was clinical medicine.
And as a result,
I had the opportunity to intern in venture
capital to found a business of my own,
to work on a number of different
actually global health projects.
And at the end of that, for me,
the biggest thing was where can I have the
biggest impact, the most outsized impact?
And at least early in my career,
I thought the best way for
me to do that would be to
go into venture capital.
And have the opportunity to fund
healthcare technology startups that can
bring tech that's much needed into
healthcare into the ecosystem much faster,
and much more efficiently.
>> Excellent, thank you so much.
There was a question in the audience
specifically around entrepreneurship,
and starting ventures
from being at the GSB.
And Norris, I'd love for you to share
a bit more about your journey so
far from kind of aerospace engineering,
pre-GSB, to starting a company.
How did the GSB specifically equip you,
and help you along that journey?
And why did you decide to go to
business school given that goal?
>> Cool.
Yeah, so for me,
it's been a pretty long journey to
start the company that I have now,
which is sort of the supersonic
commercial aviation company.
Well, I had the idea when
I was in high school.
It was just generally about faster flight.
I even wrote my admissions essay or
GSB about it.
And so a lot of like career path,
including my study led to that.
And so going to the GSB was
really the final step for
me to really start this company.
Because I gained a lot of industry
experience that I knew what
the solution was to future travel, and
they just needed to start a company.
And so I went to GSB because
of a number of factors.
One, kind of like what Sunny said,
it has a very strong departments across
the entire campus,
not only business school.
In his case, medicine, in my case,
the aerospace engineering department.
And that's where I went to actually find
my co-founder, who I work with today.
So [COUGH] that's that's one element.
Secondly, of course, the GSB is
really great, because of the classes.
The professors, the students, and
all of them helps in some way or another.
I could be more specific if you want,
in helping me.
And in addition to that,
the location is really great.
I could literally bike to several VC
offices between classes, after class,
or on the weekends, or whatever.
And that made it very convenient to
actually go talk to a lot of VCs,
establish that relationship with them.
There are some sacrifices, of course, with
starting a company during business school.
I spent a lot of time building a business,
which I basically started in
the first two weeks of school.
So I didn't really do classes
as well as I could have.
And my social life [LAUGH],
I had to prioritize my significant other
over my social life, in that regard.
>> Excellent, and Norris, could you share
one of the more specific ways in which you
really felt supported, or kind of
transformed on your journey is something
that really helped you accomplish
your goals with starting a company?
You mentioned that you
could be more specific.
Was it a class?
Was it a club activity?
Was it something that you did?
>> Yeah, it's really hard to pinpoint
just one thing, because, I mean,
there's tens of things at GSP that really
helped me build the company, right?
I mean, one was just finding my
co-founder, which is, of course,
a very monumental part of it.
And I simply just did that by emailing
some students over there, and
got in touch with the right person.
But one thing I'll mention
is a professor on campus,
and he was a board member of an airline.
And then I met him through
a microecon professor, who just,
he was talking about airlines.
And I was like, hey,
I want to talk more about airlines.
He was like,
you should meet this professor.
And I did, and then he introduced
me to several executives
at the airline that he was
a board of because of that.
And some of them still,
I'm in contact with and
have remained advisors to my company.
That's one specific-
>> That's great.
>> Way that GSB helped, mm-hm.
>> Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I saw some questions out there
both from and Michael, and
a few other questions related to clubs and
extracurricular activities.
So I'd love to maybe start with Sunny.
If you could share what
extracurriculars were you involved in?
And I know a challenge of many students
is just that there are so many.
But perhaps not only which ones were you
involved in, but what were the ones that
were most meaningful to you
during your time at the GSB?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
I think you opened it up appropriately,
and said probably the most most
challenging thing about the GSB is
that there are so many opportunities.
That it does feel like you're drinking
from the firehouse until everyone kind of
figures out what their
appropriate study state is.
For me, I chose couple of specific
activities that Were helpful.
One was just choosing to be in a couple of
industry groups that I thought would give
me, again,
that broad exposure I was looking for.
So, ended up doing way too many to begin
with, but ended up whittling it down to
a list that I felt was directly
relevant to what I would want to do,
which included the tech, the healthcare,
and the Venture Capital Group.
I also mentioned earlier
that I led a trip to Greece,
that was probably one of the more intense,
but
one of the most rewarding experiences I
had, in that I got to take 20 of my fellow
GSB classmates to Greece to understand
the healthcare ecosystem there.
And then I also got involved
in student government.
I was the Social Chair of
the Student Committee and
was able to give back a little bit
to the community by using Stanford
sponsored funds to throw events,
parties, activities that
really were able to meet
the entire needs of the community.
Everything from your big parties and
dances but also events for children,
families with children, such as
a Halloween trick or treating event.
So it was a great way to get exposed to a
very broad set of the community that I may
have not otherwise interacted with if
I just pursued my academic interests.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I'd love to hear more
about extracurriculars,
just because there were so
many questions out there about them.
So, Marlo, can you also share perhaps
what was one of your more meaningful
extracurricular activities?
>> Sure, there's a couple I think of.
I know I mentioned one, which is that I
was involved in a couple investing clubs.
Outside of that, I also actually helped
form a new club with a couple friends who
I met first year,
which is a really cool experience.
So we started a Stanford chapter of what
was called the Adam Smith Society, which
is kind of a free market-oriented club
that had some chapters in other areas and
it was a really cool experience.
We got a lot of support from
the school to get that started.
We actually, our, I think,
second year won an award for
kind of best new chapter,
which is exciting.
We had a decent cohort of
people who are involved.
We had speakers come through and whatnot.
That was a very cool experience to see
something kind of net new brought to
the school.
>> Awesome, thank you.
There are a couple panelists,
Hana and Saran,
who have specifically questions to Mariana
that we want to follow back up on about,
just pivoting into tech and
product management.
So I'd like to know from you just what
courses really helped you hone in
on product management, perhaps.
And then also you mentioned you had
started your own company afterwards.
So, similar to Nora's,
the question of just what helped you,
from the GSB, kind of go down that path?
How were you supported,
whether it was classes, faculty,
classmates, just your experience
in terms of pivoting careers, but
also specifically into tech and
product management?
>> Yeah, so
becoming a founder came first and
I sort of figured out that,
within all the things you can do in tech,
products was interesting for
me through that experience.
So becoming a founder,
it sort of came through a few things.
So one is that e-business class, just
like learning about the survey of tech
companies and how to sort of
splice through the ecosystem.
Two is that internship I mentioned and
then from there sort of came in a flurry.
One of the most important classes
was Lean Launchpad with Steve Blank.
And so, in that class,
it's across a few schools.
So you pair up with folks who might
come from the engineering school or
other graduate programs.
And your job is to build a business.
And so through the course of the class,
you come up with an idea with your team
and then you just pivoting constantly.
So like every two to three weeks,
you're iterating on your idea.
You're in the field talking
to customers constantly.
And that class is really eye opening
because you learn how to be scrappy,
like one of Steve Blank's points was that
if you never get kicked out of a store,
you really aren't trying hard enough.
[LAUGH] Or it's like, you just need
to do these these very scrappy,
crazy things or to figure out how
to get things off the ground.
And so that helped to sort of
catapult me into becoming a founder.
At the time, we had a program where,
for a few months after graduating,
you could actually have
an office on campus.
So I actually worked out of an office
at the GSB for a while, which is great.
And then from there I ran my company and
in the sort of flow of what I was doing.
I was doing all the roles,
helping with design, helping with EnG,
because I had the EnG background,
helping with products, helping the sales.
I figured out that I liked product
the most, just what gave me energy.
And so when I decided to switch into
Facebook, I pursued product and marketing.
And thank goodness for me, because I don't
think I'd be the greatest marketer in
the world, I ended up finding
a great fit with product.
But I think we now have more
coursework dedicated to product.
It's a really exciting space.
It's a very sort of made up career,
like it didn't exist the way it is now,
20 years ago.
And so it's one where you
having a lot of flexibility and
the ability to really think
on your feet goes a long way,
which is a lot of what you
learn in business school.
And also part of it, to be honest,
like one of those key skills that I gained
that's really helpful is being able to
confidently make something up on the spot.
[LAUGH] Because I had to project
confidence all day long and
like I normally know exactly into
all details what's going on, but
there's some times where it's like, you're
making what I call a 49, 51 decision.
There's a 49% chance this,
and a 51% chance it's that.
But no matter what call you make,
you need to drive your team forward in
that path, and those are the hard ones.
And then so, for those 49, 51s,
being able to, on the spot,
explain, help the team to become competent
behind that idea, goes a long way.
That's something that I learned
through a series of debates and
other coursework at Stanford.
>> Awesome, thank you so much for sharing.
We have a question from Marielle, and
I hope I pronounced your name correctly,
just, what is the role of the GSB in
the lives of our panelists post GSB?
So how have you been involved afterwards
and I first, again, point out they're
all here as panelists, which is an awesome
way for them to be involved and give back.
But, because this is the western region,
I'd love to have Vidya start by
answering this question and talk about,
perhaps, the alumni community
up in the Pacific Northwest and
in the Seattle area, where you're based,
and then we'll have someone
else share what it's like in
a different part of the West Coast.
>> I actually, I might take that question
differently than how you directed me,
if that's okay, Lisa [LAUGH].
>> Sure.
>> We do have an alumni presence up here.
There are events that happen
from time to time like talks and
we have a summer event every year, etc.
And I definitely take part in those but
I actually feel like the way that GSB
shows up in my life now is pretty separate
from that, which is primarily like
the community of my class and
kind of a few specific sub communities.
So there's one thing that kind of grew
organically is there's a group of
about ten of us from my class
who all have deep passion for
International Development work and
social issues and we formed a group
back in 2013 or something and have been
getting together in person once a year,
and five of those people
live in Sub-Saharan Africa.
I live in the US.
And we still get together in person once a
year, and we have several kind of meetings
throughout the year where we
choose an organization to back,
an area we want to learn about, etc.
And they're just very, very close friends.
So that's been an amazing community, just
in terms of shared interest, and also,
we help each other career wise.
The other thing that's been amazing
just in the last month or so
is all of the stuff that's going on
right now on systemic racism and
social unrest here in the US.
My entire class of 2012 has come together
in this massive WhatsApp group around
Black Lives Matter.
And has really been activating each other,
and finding resources, and
finding actions that we can take
collectively, both with the GSB, and
kind of outside in our communities.
And that's actually just been phenomenal
to connect with people that way, and
have so many leaders that have
a lot of power out of the world,
trying to kind of activate
themselves to make a difference.
So it shows up a lot, and it's the most
powerful part of going to the GSB,
is your classmates, I think.
>> Awesome, thank you so much for sharing.
Let's go back to perhaps Marlo,
who's in Los Angeles.
So also in kind of non Bay Area,
if you could tell us how the GSB
shows up in your life post GSB?
>> Absolutely, so
even from a macro perspective,
similarly to what said,
my class is very close.
We have all different sorts of
programming and interaction points.
We, even during COVID, started doing
twice a month, sort of career talks,
where people on Saturday
mornings talk about what they do.
And some of the interesting things about
this, just to continue to give people
interesting ideas of career paths, which I
think is really cool that just sprung up.
And then more of a local front,
I mean, we have actually
a pretty vibrant LA community.
Thinking about even tonight,
my class is having to get together
to celebrate one of our classmates.
She's finishing residency today.
And there's a number of us, obviously,
a small group we get together.
But pretty cool that we have a tight
knit community down here that we have,
especially during times where
we're allowed to see each other.
Birthday parties, and get togethers
,and book clubs, and stuff like that,
which I think is cool,
especially removed from the Bay Area.
>> Awesome, thanks.
And then I'd love maybe Mariana,
if you could chime in as
representing the Bay Area.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Just kind of what role does the GSB
play in your life as an alum?
>> Yeah, I'm lucky.
I'm super close.
I think it depends on time.
So the first year after, the GSBers who
were in the Bay Area hung out constantly.
Yeah, I think I'd see a GSBer
probably every other day.
[LAUGH] We were really,
really, really tight.
It's waned over time.
So now I have a select group of folks who
were actually across my class in videos
class who I hang out with a lot,
just my friend group.
And then otherwise,
I just see people very often.
So coming from the Bay Area just
absolutely filled with GSBers,
including the one I work with now.
And so
I just normal course coming across GSBers.
In terms of formal programming,
my class has,
we used to do an annual football game,
so a massive cookout.
And then go to the game together,
and we'd have a DJ playing.
We'd have caterers come in,
it's this big deal.
Obviously, I don't think
that's happening this year.
But otherwise, honestly, in the Bay Area,
it happens pretty organically,
because GSBers are everywhere,
and so that's been my experience.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I'm going to direct this next
question to Norris as the most recent
graduate of the program.
Jordan in the audience asked just how did
classes adapt to stay relevant to
perhaps what may have been going
on in the world, or
in business at that time?
Did you experience
anything like that where
there was innovation taking place in the
classroom itself by the course offerings?
>> I'm probably not going to answer
the question how you're hoping.
So I was really curious about
what GSB was doing with COVID-19.
And so I actually knew a professor who I
reached out to for some other stuff, and
I asked if I can participate in class.
And so he did, of course,
a lot of lectures are on Zoom, and
he did his lecture on Zoom.
And that was one way that
he adopted the class, and
I thought it was actually
really well done.
And having taken the course
both in person and
online, I actually noticed very
little decrease in quality.
And there was still audience,
or student participation.
They brought in a guest speaker as well.
And then the guest speaker was
really engaging in a lot of student
questions as well.
And they did a case review.
So talk about adaptation, I mean, that was
just done on the fly in a couple weeks.
And that was not just one professor, but
it was en masse across the entire program.
So that's one way.
>> Yeah, and just to echo on that,
it's something that happened very quickly,
and that's great to hear that you
were able to take part in that, and
see that experience.
And perhaps we could have someone
else chime in about that, and
just about the courses offered during that
time in their relevancy to that time.
Maybe Sunny, you could chime in if there
were any courses you saw developed,
or offered that were specific to
just changes happening in business,
or the world at that time.
>> I think one of the major
things that I saw, and
was actually a part of was expanding
the GSBs healthcare offerings.
And healthcare is an industry that's
growing tremendously quickly, and
it has been for a while.
But especially from the business side,
the tech side,
which Stanford is so good at excelling.
They've been able to bring together
even more expertise in the area.
And I think that's actually shown up
in either directly as a result of,
or as part of student demand.
At least in my class,
I know that the healthcare club was one of
the largest groups that was
active from a industry focus.
And what I found was that
the GSB was very responsive, and
that if they get demand from
the students to explore a new area,
find some faculty support,
launch programs, launch clubs.
As long as you have student interest,
you can almost always get
something off the ground.
And I absolutely saw it happen in real
time with healthcare offerings at the GSB.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I see a few questions that relate
to just kind of the general
the GSB, and
this is a really broad question.
We only have a few minutes left,
but I would love to pose that out.
We'll start maybe with video just
about kind of not just why the GSB,
because you've touched on
that a little bit already.
But also,
how did you know it was the right time for
you to apply to business law?
We're seeing a couple few
questions out there around that.
>> Yeah, I mean, I think there's
probably as many answers to this
question as people that you talk to,
because it's such a personal decision.
In terms of timing, I think for me,
again, like I mentioned before,
I kind of knew I wanted to gain
a certain skill set that was
around understanding how companies work.
And understanding how you can well
run an organization, and then go and
apply that in the field of
international development.
And I felt I had accumulated a certain
number of years in experiences
out there in the private sector,
and I was kind of ready.
I just kind of felt like it was like okay,
the marginal return of another year, or
another couple years, versus going and
actually doing what I want to do.
Isn't worth it and that so I was I think
four years out when I went to the GSB.
So that that motivated the timing,
it was gut feel, I mean who knows
if it was the right decision.
And then in terms of why Stanford,
for me, there was one personal factor,
which is my now husband was
getting his PhD at Stanford.
So that was an attractive feature
being back in the same place.
But that actually wasn't
the primary motivator,
I think I could have
easily like moved out and
gotten a job in the Bay Area if we
just wanted to be in the same place.
I think for me, it was really
the combination of things that
Stanford was kind of really
exceptionally known for.
So one was the interdisciplinary nature of
all the schools, knowing I wanted to work
kind of in healthcare and
innovation that was usually attractive.
And really, I think was really true,
like what everyone says is even
more true once you get there.
I think a lot of focus really on personal
growth and kind of developing as a leader,
which I didn't get that vibe necessarily
from other schools that I looked at and
it is the most important
thing to invest and
I think in ourselves at that time today
before we kind of go on to other roles.
Unless there's just kind of like the
innovation spirit I think that's part of
Stanford which now is like so well known
and was well known at that time too.
But I think there's just something really
special there about how you want the world
to be, you have the ability to create and
that is like just such a cool thing to
be around even if it's people that are,
I'm not in tech, but it's cool to be
around people that are doing that in tech.
So it's like a combination of all those
things that felt really special and
talking to folks that had been
there that validated that.
>> Yeah, awesome, thanks, Vidia.
So you guys, we have three minutes left.
I do want to wrap up with one question
that I'll direct towards two of you.
Which is,
we've had a lot of folks out there ask
questions around just admissions advice,
and just general things like that.
And we do have information sessions
that focus a bit more on the admissions
process, which I'll talk about in
a minute, but I would love maybe Sunny and
then Marlowe, so we'll start with Sunny.
If you could go back to your pre-GSB self,
maybe what is a piece of
advice you might give?
>> That's a great question.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, [LAUGH] I think that probably
the most important thing that
I would give to myself prior
to coming to the GSB is
absolutely keep an open mind.
Be willing to take on a broad exposure but
also don't try and do everything.
I think the number one thing that at least
I ran into I know many of my colleagues
did, was there's just so
much opportunity that being able
to narrow it down to what you're
passionate about, is not easy.
It's almost like it's a curse of
having too many good options, and
too many good opportunities
to create pursuit.
So while you should absolutely take the
opportunity to try many different things,
figure out what really calls to you and
then spend as much time
as you can pursuing that.
>> Awesome, thanks.
And Marlowe,
anything kind of advice you
would give to your pre-GSB self?
>> Yeah, Sunny took mine which has made
the most of the time because there's
always so many things to choose from.
But I guess the other one I would say
too is, I just long lines of being
open minded and thinking about looking at
coursework or speaking to individuals that
might be outside of the realm of
the backgrounds you came from.
I mean I think about either some of
the people that I got exposed to who just
opened my eyes to other career paths,
other ways of thinking.
Or even some of the coursework where I
took classes that maybe it happened to fit
into my schedule at one point and it turns
out is actually the most interesting
classes I took not knowing what
things would resonate later.
So I think having that breath and
that open mindedness to kind of
using the time to have as many
experiences as possible while also
knowing you won't get to do everything
is a good mindset to come in with.
>> Awesome, thank you so much.
And with that,
I am going to share one more slide,
just as we close out this
session with everyone.
I know that we're doing a lot of these
events virtually right now at this time.
But I do want to share on our campus,
we have a cornerstone on the gun building,
which is one of the buildings on the night
management center of the business school.
And it reads dedicated to the things
that haven't happened yet and
the people who are about to dream them up.
So I want to thank our five
panelists today for joining us.
I hope that what you heard from
them today was inspirational and
motivational and
excited you about the GSB and
also gave you an idea of what it's like
to be a student when you're at the GSB.
I did mention that we have a lot of other
events offered throughout the summer.
So I wanted to encourage everyone
who's on this session with us today.
To check back on our events page on the
Stanford GSB admissions events webpage,
we have information sessions.
These are sessions that include a bit more
information about the MBA program and
the admissions process.
You joined us today for
our regional panel.
This was the western region but
we do have industry panels and
women's panels and
diversity panels throughout the summer.
So I encourage you to see the offerings
and the dates that we have those on.
And then we also have a lot of what we
call small group chats at a broader level.
You can have a chance to do a small
group chat with and meet an AO,
an admissions officer like myself or
one of my colleagues, or
meet a student or meet an alum events.
So again, we encourage you to take
advantage of these offerings we
have online this summer.
We're excited to have the opportunity
to share information with you and
get a chance to meet you virtually.
Should you have any follow-up
questions from today's session?
We've also included our email address and
our office hours where you
can always call with more
follow up questions if we weren't able to
get your specific question answered today.
So again, I want to thank you Mariana,
Marlowe, Vidia,
Sunny and Norris, thank you so much for
joining us today and thanks to all of you.
And we hope to see you again
at a future event this summer.
[MUSIC]